Are there certain gene variations I should be looking at in my genetic report to see a
glyphosate might be causing a problem in my body, or is it just any of the detox related genes?
I've already taken two teaspoons of liposomal glutathione and three tablespoons
of ground tuna per day. So the glutathione is going to help both phase one in phase two in the liver
plus it's going to help with into a cellular detoxification of glyphosate and anything. So
what gene variations should you look at? The NAT genes, the PON1 genes, the cytokron P450 genes,
it's all your detoxification pathways, your catalyse genes, your superoxide genes,
on those would be the things that you could think of. Most people don't have glyphosate problems
because they have solely because they have genetic defects. They have glyphosate problems because
they have glyphosate exposure. So you could say well why doesn't everybody have glyphosate problems?
The answer is everybody probably does have glyphosate problems, especially in the United States.
It had a nice long conversation with Agal from Germany, who's living in the United States. No,
my daughters were talking to her for quite a while. Talking about all of the pesticides and herbicides
and things have been banned in Europe. So if you could get a hold of food that's imported,
you're probably better off.